romeo first
you look amazing i am stunned you are
stunning or a stunning human but i am so
excited to talk to you today
congratulations on making the final
three of survivor 42 how are you feeling
oh first of all thank you erica i'm a
big fan um and yeah isn't it crazy like
we don't we don't look like crap people
like we didn't get another union so we
didn't get that that glow-up moment but
this is it you know um
i feel very proud i mean i i made it
farther than i ever thought i would make
it i made it you know exceeded the
expectations of many of my own family
and friends who thought i would be first
voted out so the fact that i made it
past the first vote and then passed the
pre-merge and then you know pass the
merge and all the way to the final three
and winning that final immunity
challenge i mean i i definitely
outperformed their expectations not my
own um
but i'm definitely proud of the game
that i had to play i didn't have a lot
of options a second part of this game so
i'm definitely proud
you should be proud because i think that
survivor is so much about getting the
hand that you're dealt and knowing how
to play with it and i think you did such
an amazing job at that and i want to
talk about that final immunity challenge
because i watched the show with a bunch
of friends and we were screaming jumping
up and down we were losing it when you
won congratulations
tell me about that challenge and what
that moment was like uh yeah thank you i
mean i it's funny because so many fans
are sending me videos of the different
bars and the different parties that they
attended of everyone cheering so that's
so awesome and uh really touches me um
that meant a lot to me i knew that um i
had at that point perception is reality
out there and i knew the perception that
people had of me out there wasn't
necessarily reality but it's unfortunate
i'll blame myself for that
so i knew that i had to prove
to them most importantly to myself that
i could
go all the way to the final three and
and put myself there in one of those
chairs not have somebody take me not
somebody just you know feel like i'm you
know an easy go to take to the final
three but just really earn it so i had
to win that new challenge and now i
never thought i mean competing with
jonathan beating jonathan in an immunity
challenge i mean come on goliath himself
like you know the the skinny guy
up against jonathan so it meant so much
to me um and i but i was determined i
was not going to lose that it was
fantastic it was so much fun to watch
and so you win the challenge you get to
make the decision on who you bring with
you
can you walk me through your decision
making there
there was a lot you know what we didn't
see was that i actually contemplated
pulling a chris underwood and giving
somebody the immunity i the muni
necklace and putting myself through fire
because i think you saw episode four i
was pretty good at making fires um so i
was pretty confident in my fire making
skills but at that point i was like you
know what um
so i contemplated that and then i
thought okay i think my best bet at that
point i felt like i was playing for
second i knew that there was no way that
i was going to win but i thought okay
let me play for a second the best shot
is uh taking jonathan with me um and
then making mike lose to jonathan in
fire that didn't happen and then when
mike when i was like okay i'm either
gonna lose to mike or marianne but it
also the second part to that was i'm
gonna
be honest and say it was also an
emotional decision because there was no
way that i could cut marianne we were an
alliance the under birdies which they
didn't show in the edit me her and omer
not the underdogs because obama doesn't
like dogs so he wanted to be
on their birdies and then marianne was
one you know i knew me and marianne were
at the bottom for a long time and for a
long time she was a supporter for me in
every challenge you saw a little bit of
it last night you know she would always
encourage me in every challenge she
would always uh uplift me when i was
feeling down of being at the bottom and
she was just so
so you know so um like such a a strong
supporter of me out there that there was
no and she reminded me so much of the
young woman that i work with back home
in pageantry so there was no way that i
could cut her it was definitely also a
very emotional decision for me and i
thought at some point if i'm going to
lose to somebody i'd rather lose to
marianne um and i there was no way i was
going to be grudger a million dollars
and the title saw survivor so i was um
very happy for her
wow that's amazing and i really enjoyed
you in the final tribal council because
i feel like you had a clear view of
where you stood and i think you were
open about what you were able to do well
and then where you had struggles and you
still accepted them and overcame them
and i feel like similar to you i also
spent some time at the bottom when i was
playing and people don't realize there's
a bit of an art to playing from the
bottom so can you talk a bit about
strategically what you need to do when
you're at the bottom to keep going in
the game
at some point it was so weird because
eric like at the pre-merge i was at the
top
i was not going anywhere and then
getting to the post merge going to the
bottom it was an adjustment so i quickly
realized that i was at the bottom and
had to uh change my game it's so much
easier playing survivor when you have
the numbers and people that want to play
with you as opposed to not having the
numbers and having nobody want to play
with you so at that point i just had to
get by another tribal get by another
tribal get by another tribal as long as
it's not me the the sandra diaz twine
strategy and it was like i quickly
realized that you know what if i just
laid back these big people the in the
eight person alliance are gonna start
eating each other up and that's exactly
what happened a lot of times fans
wouldn't understand that i would throw
out vote like random votes and it was
because people forgot about you know i
always knew was going home but what if
the main target would play a hidden
immunity idol that we didn't know about
play their shot in the dark and it
worked or played an advantage that we
didn't know i mean it's survivor 42
survivor 41 you know there's so many
like advantages now so uh so what would
happen if the main target did one of
those things who was going home
in case romeo that was my nickname in
case romeo was going home or if there
was a revo who was going home me so if i
threw a vote through another person then
um if the main target played one of
these things and it worked then the
person that i voted for would go home
well maybe among the players in the game
you were in case romeo but i feel like
for the viewers what we're going to
remember about you is how you were just
brave enough to be so vulnerable about
how you were trying to reconcile your
sexuality and your culture and i think
that so many people got so much out of
seeing you be open about those struggles
so what was it like for you to watch
that back and what's been the response
from your family and from your community
it's been overwhelmingly positive both
from my family and the survivor fans
my family the ones that didn't know you
know i want to clarify because i do live
my life as the out proud gay man to my
immediate family my friends my
co-workers but there was a huge part of
my family that i haven't seen in years
that didn't know so those were the ones
i were referring to and and their
response was uh positive i got a lot of
phone calls from them about how proud
they were of me that nothing changes and
that they love me regardless and then on
the other end which was even more
surprising was the positive response
from
the fans the viewers from around the
world
uh messages from kids who would tell me
you know i'm watching the episode with
my parents sitting on the couch and i
and they don't know about me so thank
you for giving me the courage to maybe
come out to them and then on the other
hand the parents would message me saying
you know um i'm scared that you know i
was so fearful that my my uh children
were part of the community and i don't
know if i would be okay with that but
then seeing you and your struggles it
made me realize that if they when they
do come out i don't want them to feel
that we're not going to love them and
accept them
and then even people from other places
around the world like someone as far as
iran messaged me and how are they
watching survivor in iran like maybe a
vpn or something but the message said
you know um i live in a country where
being gay is not okay so seeing somebody
like you
talk about that and uh i made me feel
seen and feel safer and more comfortable
so it's been overwhelming the responses
have been so positive and i feel eric i
feel like a winner anyways because of
that i felt like i was the real winner
of survivor i didn't need a million
dollars to prove that
in the final tribal it looked like you
knew that you were taking something away
that was so impactful i think that
that's why i enjoyed watching you at the
final tribal so much and i know that
you're a pageant coach so what is the
lesson that you're going to take from
survivor that you're going to bring into
your pageant coaching
well the one thing that i that i always
tell the girls that i coach in padentry
is to
never give up
even if you don't want your first
pageant or you don't place in your first
page and just keep trying keep trying
it's kind of like my life lesson with
survivor you know um i for a long time
i'm a super fan and i never applied
because i was scared of rejection
and then the the one time that i applied
i got on so that was a big lesson for me
and then to tell them like you never
know what you're capable of until you
put yourself out there so that's one and
then also just never give up i never
gave up on myself even though i was at
the bottom and i knew that maybe i
didn't you know i
very slim chance of winning i just
wanted to prove to myself that i could
make it as far as i could on my own
accord and win a challenge and you know
and dictate the the remainder of the
game or who was gonna go and who was
gonna
uh stay
and i felt like in a way i kind of
dictated who was going to win because i
knew that by taking marianne she was
going to win and i could and i and i and
i was happy about that so
the lesson that i'm going to give them
is to never give up and keep trying
because you just never know what's going
to happen
i love it
so what's next for you romeo
you know the funny thing is that people
ask me like what people don't realize is
that um before survivor i'm a pageant
coach yes but i'm also a television
producer i'm a three-time emmy award
winner you know i've traveled well to
six continents i work with celebrities i
own my own beauty pageant uh under the
miss universe organization so there's a
lot of things that i that i that i do
uh and survivor was just another
thing added to my to my uh life's resume
that i dreamed of
um so i think so so people are always
asking me like what's next for you you
which you wanted emmy you got that you
wanted to work in pension you did that
you want to be on survivor you're on
survivor okay so now what and it's like
well besides going on survivor again and
winning a million dollars
i think it's finally focusing on myself
now that i can be my authentic uh my
true self find love find mr right hit
the dms
and you know and just maybe start a
family i'm in my 30s it's time so i'm
excited for the next chapter in my life
i am so excited for you i know whatever
is next on the horizon you're going to
do an amazing job and romeo i want to
say thank you so much for chatting today
i loved watching you i'm so proud of you
i hope you're proud of yourself and i
wish you all of the best thank you erica
thank you so much
you